r
est plus importante et
évidemment, ça peut poser
problème pour les gens qui ont
la santé fragile.
- Le sud du Québec s'est
réveillé dans la brume.
Ce matin, on aurait dit
qu'un voile enveloppait
la métropole.
- J'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie.
À Montréal, ça fait un peu
bizarre.
- Le ciel est un peu plus
obscuré, je ne vois pas
très clairement.
- On se questionnait justement,
comment ça se fait que c'était
si intense hier, la luminosité
était étrange.
- Un panache de fumée provenant
des feux de forêt qui font rage
dans le nord-ouest de l'Ontario
s'est déplacé jusqu'au Québec.
C'est ce qui a causé l'épisode
de smog qui a touché plusieurs
régions du sud de la province,
de l'Outaouais jusqu'à Québec,
en passant par le Grand
Montréal. Du jamais-vu
depuis 2013.
SIMON LEGAULT, météorologue,
Environnement Canada
- C'est rare qu'on a
un événement au Québec comme ça
qui touche à un large pan
de la province, des grands
territoires comme ça.
Donc, les panaches de fumée,
des fois, viennent nous visiter,
des fois, ils font juste rester
en altitude, ils ne touchent pas
à la qualité de l'air,
ne viennent pas proche du sol.
- La qualité de l'air s'est
aussi détériorée dans le sud
de l'Ontario et dans l'ensemble
des provinces de l'Ouest
en raison des feux de forêt
qui se sont déclarés
un peu partout au pays.
Le smog fait référence
à une pollution atmosphérique
plus importante qu'à l'habitude.
C'est un mélange toxique
de gaz et de particules
qui peut s'avérer
potentiellement dangereux
pour les plus vulnérables.
Dr PIERRE GOSSELIN, INSPQ
et chercheur, Ouranos
- Ça accélère dans le fond
les problèmes de santé pour ceux
qui sont déjà fragiles.
Alors, on va voir des excès
d'hospitalisations,
des excès de décès.
- Les aînés, les personnes
aux prises avec des problèmes
cardiaques et les asthmatiques
sont particulièrement à risque.
- Quand on est fragile,
on reste à la maison fenêtres
fermées évidemment, et puis
quand on a à sortir, on évite
l'exercice trop violent.
Dr FRANÇOIS REEVES, cardiologue,
spécialiste santé environnement.
- La pollution atmosphérique
au Canada tue 15 000 personnes
en exécdent tous les ans
et surtout, 120 milliards de
dollars de soins de santé.
- Selon Environnement Canada,
l'épisode de smog qui touche
le Québec devrait être terminé
d'ici demain. On pourra respirer
un peu mieux.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, M